l'innovation technologique l'innovation
digitale au service de la filière
agricole en centre val de loire les
idées ne manquent pas au nord de
chartres dans son tracteur luc laurin
est a priori un agriculteur comme les
autres s'il exerce bien son métier
d'exploitant céréaliers sur 320 hectares
avec son frère ce n'est pas là
l'essentiel de son activité
mathématicien météorologues et
agriculteurs
il est un peu les trois à la fois ce géo
trouvetou a recueilli en trente ans un
nombre incalculable de métadonnées dans
le monde entier pour mieux anticiper
c'est la passion de mon métier la
passion des mathématiques la passion
d'agronomie la physiologie de plantes
je suis né avec une paire de bottes et
un ordinateur alors de la donne et céda
données de data de météo n'a donné de
relever stade dans tous les pays du
monde de rendement de certains pays de
certaines régions et tout ça j'ai tout
doux tout agrémenté pour planifier pour
chacun des pays et l'objectif pour moi
c'est de
de prévoir de prévoir pour lui et pour
ses clients et justement ce jour-là
l'ucl data culteurs retrouve l'un de ses
rares clients français au sud de droite
remporte son argent un peu probable
on voit bien les dégâts
[Musique]
grâce aux outils d'aidé à la décision et
à l'analyse précise réalisée par luc
laurin christophe barret a vendu avant
la moisson l'essentiel de sa production
d'orge
concrètement j'ai vendu 100 % de mon
ange voilà dans un look division grâce à
l'outil parce que en ayant une
estimation de rendement mon acheteur a
bien voulu acheter une surface avec un
rendement dont on n'a pas la certitude
du tonnage pour l'instant mais on a
quand même un élément concret que
l'estimation donc ça c'est assez nouveau
jusque là on ne vend que des tonnages et
moi aujourd'hui j'ai vendu des ha c'est
très simple d'utilisation parce que on
reçoit quatre pages alors après le
service il peut être plus ou moins
complet c'est à la carte mais moi je
reçois quatre pages tous les quinze
jours et et ça me dit tout pour pour
toutes mes cultures quoi parfois
incompris en france considéré comme un
original par les coopératives les
semenciers luc laurin a développé
essentiellement son idée ailleurs en
proposant des outils d aide à la
décision en europe de l'est
sa part ayant parfois j'ai pas pu ça
fait 20 ans que le faire j'ai pas pu le
faire dans trois ans ou à mx et écho au
gore ça fait deux ans j'ai connu s'il ne
start up qui récupère des images un dvi
et des images satellites et à partir de
ces images satellites il décède de
déterminer de mettre en place différents
os à des prévisions de rendement risque
maladie etc à partir de qui m'achètent
l'été données météo pour apporter des
outils d'aidé à la décision pour les
agriculteurs dont qu'en roumanie on
s'occupe de 2,7 lui ferme
qui ont entre 2 et 15 villes état
entrepreneur innovant dans une filière
traditionnelle luc laurin a dans le même
temps lancé son application pour
anticiper maladie et prévisions de
rendement
[Musique]